من جهه هي اعلنت الاداره العسكريه في
مقاطعه دونيتسك شرقيه اوكرانيا عن مقتل
اربعه مدنيين واصابه ثلاثه في قصف روسي
استهدف مناطق تريدسك
وتورسكي امس الاثنين وجددت اداره المقطعه
من طلبتها سكان المنطقه بالتوجه الى اماكن
اكثر امنا
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه تعرض مناطق
كوبيانسكف لقصف صاروخين اسفر عن اصابه شخص
واحد بجروح
الى
61 مره خلال يوم واحد
افاد موقع ريبار العسكري الروسيه ان قوات
فاجنر تواصلوا استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه
داخل مدينه بخموت والمدن المحيطه بها في
شرق اوكرانيا
على الاحياء السكنيه في مركز المدينه
وتتقدم من المركز باتجاه الشمع وذكر
الموقع ان قوات تهاجم المواقع الاوكرانيه
في حي السيليشي وتخوض معارك مع القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط محطه القطارات في
المدينه
توقعت جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه
البريطاني ان تنشئ روسيا شركات عسكريه
خاصه لتحل محل شركه فاجنر في دورها
القتالي في اوكرانيا وعزت الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ذلك في سلسله تغريدات يوميه عن
مجريات الحرب في اوكرانيا الى وجود خلافات
كبيره بين شركه فاغنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسي